Mark.
Yes, hi.
Do you know why I'm upset with you right now?
No.
I've told you a million times to refill the roll when it's done...
...and put the toilet seat back down.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
Step one: conflict resolution.
Do it in a way they understand.
Mark, when you don't refill the roll, it's like you left me with no extra ammo,...
...knowing I'm on my last bit of health.
I am so sorry, I did not mean to kill you.
I will replace the toilet paper and I'll put the seat down.
Thank you.
Now if you'll excuse me, I have to fire off some shots.
Oh, are you gonna play while you're on the toilet again?
No.
I had Mexican again.
Can I play with you?
Sure.
So, wait, I just use this move?
Yeah, but don't worry, I'll go easy on ya.
Seems pretty simple, to be honest.
It's not that simple.
I'm doing pretty good, actually.
Well, maybe...
Oh look at me, I'm like, killing you.
Okay, calm down a little bit.
Like, you're dying.
Hang on.
I am destroying you right, this is easy.
I am going super easy on you.
My God, this is what you do all day?
Oh my God!